everybody I'm rich roll I'm your host
this is my podcast welcome to it got a
great guest for you guys today
Charlie Jabba lay yesterday how you
doing doing amazing this guy has an
amazing story how you are like 304
pounds 304 pounds only like nine months
ago training for an Ironman right now
completely changed his life it's an
unbelievably inspirational story and I
can't wait to share with you guys what
we talked about today we talked about
reversing brain tumors we talked about
tumor we talked about quantum physics
energy and we talked about how I use
quantum physics to meet you it was a
great talk and I talked about eating
live plants yes is it dead or alive
because I was dying literally and I was
eating a whole bunch of dead food and
then when I changed it eating living
food I started living and my brain tumor
started shrinking and you found your
purpose in life I did so it's a
conversation about life purpose changing
your life transformation and the unique
potential that I think lives and resides
within all of us to unlock and unleash a
better more authentic more fully
actualized version of ourselves that's
right so tune in perfect guest for the
new year and kickstart your January and
gets you in the right frame of mind
mindset tackle your goals and unleash
that beast within yourself right
superhero cool
so I hope you guys enjoy it leave a
comment below let us know what you
thought and
you sound good dude you ready to do this
Charlie's in the house man get some good
energy you're gonna get it it's gonna be
awesome dude
I can't wait to like share your story
it's so powerful Thank You Man it's cool
to have you here you know the history of
this is pretty funny man you are like
peppering me with emails for a long time
I was like who is this guy eventually I
just I just got worn out but also like
your story seemed cool and we connected
and I was like wow it's pretty powerful
I think what you've what you've
accomplished what you've what you've had
to face the obstacles you've had to
overcome and and kind of where you find
yourself now so let's break it down dude
thank you what do you want to start with
me bothering you because when I moved
here I was like Idol eyes you obviously
like you really you really do have like
some serious disciples and like me
moving to California and and and
following your story it was like um man
I have to know this guy like I just have
to and I I told you a little bit about
it Oh after we met I called you and
Heather like tell you like the story but
the I in my notebook I'll show you a
picture in my notebook I um I wrote down
a draft board like you know NBA teams or
any sports team they draft who they want
right on their team and I was like
here's a draft board and you'll you'll
see your name right there boom I see I
took a picture of it like as a ritual
I've got a draft rich roll into my life
hold on looking like so weight lost
motivation
yes yeah yeah and this was this was
September right so I was still like I
was I was I was just I was just a fan
and I boom I wrote you down in my
notebook
and then I got a DM and just the next
week from this this kid named Roberto
language Mexican kid and I he's like I'm
in Venice like let's link up
and I'm mentoring a whole lot of people
and I'm like just a guy who is like on
your radar what's I don't get it he just
he just found me he I guess he knew
somebody that knew me and he told him
about me and he deemed me so he came
over to my house and I just was I tell
everybody what I'm excited about I'm
like really excited about like rich role
because like I want to be a vegan
endurance athlete as well and and this
is a week after the draft board
he said oh I crashed on rich rolls couch
a couple years ago want me to connect to
an email with him I was like yes I was
like that's it I wrote it down and boom
now the opportunity is real the universe
conspired to like make it happen man is
rule yeah and then you told me Nestor I
was like Roberto who's that and we have
so many people that like pass through
our house and crash on our cat we're
always like taking in strays but then I
was like he was the guy who was riding
his bike doing some kind of global bike
adventure right and I remember that he
stayed at our house for a night or two
that's right yeah that's cool and we
were able to connect the dots man and
here we are we got together
there's told me a little bit about your
story you shared with me a draft of this
video that I hope you'll let me share
maybe we didn't even share the audio of
it in the intro lead up to this podcast
because it's really powerful and I kind
of really compact fully you know
concisely kind of shares this adventure
that you're on but it's inspiring man I
think for me you know people ask me all
the time you know who are your favorite
guests like who are some of your
favorite interviews and of course it's
like well you're asking me to choose
amongst my babies like I love everybody
that I have on or I wouldn't have them
on hmm but I think the people that
really stand out is special for me or
when I can shine a light or put a
microphone in front of somebody who's an
individual that perhaps isn't
necessarily a public figure or somebody
that everybody knows or that has a book
out or something like that just somebody
who's had to face and overcome like
unbelievable obstacles and struggles in
their life to to persevere and and and I
find a lot of power and hope and
inspiration in those stories and it's
it's personally cool for me
when I find somebody like that and I get
to share their message so I kind of
you're you're you're an extraordinary
individual I don't consider you like an
everyman type person by any stretch of
the imagination but I think your story
in the context of health is something
that a lot of people can relate to and
and hopefully we'll be able to find
their own strength in your trials and
tribulations and and victories thank you
and that's why I appreciate you so much
for having me on because like I always
had this romantic relationship with a
million dollars like you know like that
thought like a million dollars and then
through my transformation I formed a
different type of relationship with the
word a million and like I'm on a life
mission now I want to I want to
transform a million people's lives and
like you have an audience that that
wants like they create because you are
that story like you were the one that
got away and people need so bad like
you're the one who got away like society
like I heard this story I love this
story so much rich it was about a golden
buddha and in thailand there was this
village and they all prayed to this this
buddha and this opposing army was
approaching the village and they covered
the buddha in clay and rocks so they
didn't want the other army to think it
was valuable so they covered it and this
opposing army poses a threat for many
many years and generation after
generation in this village they forgot
that this buddha was golden and one day
a boy went and sat on it on his lap and
it chipped and cracked and he looked
down at it and he saw his gold and he
ran and got his friend and they peeled
it all off and they saw that this this
this buddha was was gold
and I think that's how like people like
you and and and stories like what I
aspire to be as well is that when we're
young we hate we're golden
and then society and the rules that
everybody makes starts plastering us and
then people like me and you we get
cracked at some point in our life and
then that makes us realize that we can
see the golden again and then we take
off everything that society built on top
of us like with our careers and with
alcohol or with food and the stresses
and just what everybody told us we
should do with our lives but when we hit
that rock bottom and we get cracked we
can see we're golden again and and I I
admire you so much because you gave us
hope that we can get away too so thank
you well I appreciate that I think
you're giving me a little bit too much
credit but that's a beautiful analogy
and and you did the work man
you did the work and and I'm excited to
you know share what that was all about
so let's take it back to the beginning
southern boy southern boy growing up
maybe not in the best of circumstances
like what was it like um love my family
so much um never knew that we did
without my parents they they they worked
hard mom's old vacuum cleaners father
was a carpenter and a mechanic and was a
played the bass and a blues band and I
always had a dream I want to be an
athlete I know I was it like I loved
basketball I studied every move read
every Michael Jordan book like you name
it so it was it was Michael Jordan was
her guy Michael Jordan Allen and then
then it went to Allen Iverson and it was
just like basketball was my life I
played 24 hours a day but no matter how
much I played like I never could like
lose weight like I was a chubby kid I
was
I was the fat kid who loved basketball
it's like a conflict of interest and I
just wasn't like everybody else like
when we they would play like shirts for
skins I hated that oh my god
cuz like if I got picked for skins it
would be like I'd have to drop out like
cuz I'm I'm not I'm too embarrassed or
take myself over you at this point this
was between like eight and eleven like
like this is those years and then as I
got into like that twelve that middle
school I was like I need something to be
good at you know when you want girls to
like you and just like you're getting to
that age it's like you got to be good at
something those guys play sports and
they're good those guys can dance those
guys are attractive and I'm like none of
those so I'm like alright I'm I'm gonna
be CEO Charlie writes like I'm gonna
business so wasn't I mean a lot of those
guys turn to comedy right like that's
the that's the other route you can
pursue right you're gonna which isn't
like when you're that age it's like is
that the sexy thing to do to get girls I
don't know well you know like I've
always had a gift to see like where
culture was going like at that time it
was cool to be a thug right but I knew
you're you're like outside Atlanta or
like I mean I'm in Atlanta DeKalb County
um mmm
I grew up mixed like most of my friends
growing up were black there were a
couple white guys you know Mexican like
it was a very mixed area where I lived
and which ended up being a huge
advantage for me that I got to
experience that like I got to learn all
different types of people from day one
which led to my career you know which
was a good thing and a bad thing
so I became CEO Charlie and I was like
you just start calling yourself that
people started calling me that like in
middle school because I like I always
had a business every year was like a
different business and I like war
Sood and instead of a backpack I had a
briefcase like I took it serious like
this is me like like I knew in culture
like where I was going next like I knew
like business was cool and now you see
it like with Shark Tank I'm like Gary
Vaynerchuk and that's how Gary last
night he said hey by the way you did you
saw Gary last night yeah oh yeah yeah I
was just gonna say you had a little you
know you had a little Gary Vee hustle
going on I think youngster exactly so um
so ya got good at business and I buried
the dream like like Yahoo a dream that
athlete's dream which is the truest
dream because that's what I wanted
without instinctively that wasn't a
dream I chose that's just what I wanted
instinctively business is what I chose
to to kind of cover that up so um
business got good I got fast forward a
few years I started a music business
18 19 years old and I was just just
telling your camera guy I was the camera
guy like that's how I got started out
Soulja Boy's cameraman and I dropped out
of college to become his cameraman I
like like I remember my mom only wanted
one thing she said get your college
degree whatever like she always knew I
did business but she said just get your
degree and my first year of college like
my business was doing kind of good and I
found out that if you within the first
two weeks at community college like you
can sign up for the class and they'll
mail your parents that you signed up but
if you cancel the class you can cancel
within the first two weeks and they
don't send a notice home so so you're
buying time so it's also like I dropped
out of classes and I'm like I basically
lost my scholarship so the second year I
had to pay for school and I went up to
the school and I was just like
frustrated I remember like it was just
like how am i doing this I know I'm so
much better than this paid for my books
and everything and then I left and then
I got a call from Interscope Records
and they said there's this artist that
is a fan of your work
his name is Soulja Boy and he wants you
to go on tour with him and be his
full-time cameraman oh wow alright we're
done and what had you done to date like
you were you had done some work for him
and the past or was there other stuff
online that he had seen like how did you
get on his radar to begin with I built a
website like a hip-hop website like all
my friends started doing music and I
built this media outlet form and in
Atlanta like it became the website for
hip-hop in Atlanta and I was running it
out of my mom's basement and I had
basically the whole Underground Atlanta
hip-hop scene like coming through my
mom's house like it was it was it was it
was crazy times so if you wanted to know
what was going on in hip-hop in Atlanta
that was the site that people worked out
- that was a site like I would feature
artists on the website and then like
record labels would call the artists the
next day anybody I featured record
labels would call
the artists would call me and they're
like Warner Brothers called me or
Atlanta called me and they not feature
another artist and they would just call
everybody who I featured and so the
website was big and then one soldier boy
blew up he was like that's who I want to
be my guy hmm so you had a that's
actually a more almost a more
interesting decision than the college
versus Soulja because you're building
this website that could have turned into
like a pitchfork or something like that
for hip-hop right yes so you had to you
had to like walk away from that in order
to take a full-time gig a little bit um
it helped it helped the website because
it built my credibility um but it was it
was tough because my servers servers
back then were way more expensive than
they are now and it was like costing me
money and I wasn't getting paid much
from Soulja Boy and long story short I
went back up to the school give me money
so my mom gave me her blessing she said
when doors open you gotta walk through
them and and that's what I did I ended
up getting fired six months later and
that hurt apparently I wasn't a good
employee because well most most hardcore
entrepreneurs are right yeah they have a
hard time working for other people yeah
but maybe you need that you need to have
that experience to figure that out right
my rock bottom then was like oh man we
can't pay the bills like it was tough
like I basically had to close down my
website because I couldn't afford it
anymore it was popular but it wasn't
generating revenue and then I remember I
told my mom I'm gonna get in to
management that's where the money is she
said what do you know about management I
thought nothing but i'ma figure it out
because that's where the money is and I
signed this girl group and they were
young they were like they were they were
like like like Nickelodeon hip-hop like
it was like they were awesome and I got
him a record deal in 24 hours
because Interscope Records loved me like
they knew I knew marketing it's our God
on this record deal and three months
later they left me for a huge like
industry manager they were like yeah
well we can't have a 18 year old manager
I'm like I'm like I just keep falling on
my face like anyways so business was
interesting reason Apple thing to say
though right kind of yeah I mean I get
it but at the same time you were
delivering exactly like yeah it was but
they didn't make it so it was you know
if they stuck with me they would have
yeah you know it's rare to find somebody
who will take a bullet for you
mmm like when times are bad and there's
no money being made and that's almost
more valuable than then experience mmm
because you know times get bad yeah yeah
yeah but you have proof of concept here
you were able to get you know drum up a
record deal in no time
so you realize like hey there's
something here to pursue mm-hmm and I
found another group got right back up
signed another group and it took off and
we did I drove I like really wanted I
had to make it work and I told him I was
like their name is Travis Porter and I
told him I said just be loyal please I'm
gonna do everything
were living in their mom's house I was
living in my mom's house and they stuck
with me
we had three top ten records in the
country and then we got so hot we we
dominated Atlanta and then that's when I
was able to approach 2 Chainz and in
like I had to convince him because I was
like young and my business partners were
like we were all just like rejects like
we just we weren't the superstar
managers and he had been around artists
like Ludacris and Lil Wayne his whole
career and we're like we want to manage
you and he just laughed at us and maybe
explained for people that are listening
who don't know that much about hip-hop
who to who to changes so 2 Chainz 2
Chainz is an artist we want to grammy
this year that that really help people
understand so we want to grab me we've
had number one albums eight world tours
12 domestic tours been on Good Morning
America I've been on 2 Broke Girls
that's something they might know so yes
it's it's been a amazing amazing 10
years that uh that that that I was able
to be with 2 Chainz and to fast-forward
a little bit and to rewind and
fast-forward so I got fired on October
4th 2007 the last day of Soulja Boy's
tour that ended in Atlanta when soldier
boys fired you when Soulja Boy fired me
that was my last job I ever had and I
retired from the music industry on
October 4th 2017 the last day of two
changes tour that ended in Atlanta Wow
10 years to the date that's crazy well
there's a certain poetry to that write
in a certain symmetry see the universe
really is working in your life in
mysterious ways that you can't
comprehend charlie that's right that
brought us here today that's right so
fatso rewinding it though a little bit
like so you somehow you're able to
convince this this this guy to change
then that he should take a chance on you
that's when you're reprobate friends and
he he did and we just showed up we went
to work
and it business got big and and like I
said in the big was he at the time they
used he wasn't he had a big song like
three years prior and he was dormant
there wasn't much going on but he was he
was respected in the industry so it
wasn't just like working with a no-name
so-so business got big and in around
that time it's like business brought two
things business business brought success
which led to food and it brought stress
which led to food so it's like early in
my life at eight when I buried my dream
and went into business this business
thing was ultimately a trap for me
because everything that happened every
day is either a celebration or every day
is some sort of stress and it was
extreme and and I had got over three
hundred and four pounds and I had always
did diets and my brain was fried of just
like data like if there was a diet
jeopardy I would be like the all-time
champion of the world like 27 episodes
in a row every single one in and I was
just I was fried and I got really really
big embarrassing embarrassingly you know
obese what was the most weight 304 304
yeah person in that video you can kind
of you know you chronicled a lot of it
man yeah so you can kind of see I mean
it's kind of amazing because looking at
you now like I can't see that person at
all it's it's quite a change
thank you but what comes across in that
video and and what came across when we
talked you know the one we first got
together was the you know just the the
desperation that comes with like just
feeling trapped in this this compulsion
this addiction and and this this body
without
to be able to find any way to escape it
that's right and you you speak of your
relationship with food as as an
addictive thing is clear that like
you're like a food addict right totally
um I've never I've never done any type
of drugs or anything um I think I knew
better because I knew how I was with
food and when I like something I just
overdo it no matter what it is right
like you know that's why I guess
endurance sports is good for me I just
overdo anything so the food addiction it
sent me
it sent me to a place where I would I
was so desperate because it's one thing
to not try and get bad results I think
it makes it ten times worse when you try
so hard and you get bad results like I
was never that guy I was very ambitious
so I was never the god to to give up
like everyday it's like this is the day
like this is the game plan I'm gonna do
this and then I'll crack mainly because
of like I wasn't addressing my roots
like my tree that makes fruit is in bad
soil like that's basically what it was
like I could prune the tree all I want
above ground but it didn't matter what I
did above ground my roots are in bad
soil so I was never making fruit and
that was like my business environment
and me not fulfilling my purpose it was
just bad soil so um a guy walked into my
life Scott Cameron but before we even
get into that I wanted to just kind of
explore one thing that you said in a
little bit more depth which is this idea
of of trying like I think there's a
presumption or an assumption out there
that if you see somebody who's obese
like they've just given up they've given
up on themselves they have poor
self-esteem they don't care they've
thrown in the towel and and maybe that's
true for some people but you know your
your experience is different like you
were actually like trying to address
this the whole time and just
constantly frustrated with not being
able to get results mm-hmm yeah every
day wake up the most motivated person in
the world go to bed the most depressed
person in the world repeat that cycle
never was a day the towel was thrown in
in the morning yeah but it takes a lot
of what's right word like perseverance I
guess because if you're waking up every
day saying this is how I want the day to
go and then and then meeting your
inability to live up to that expectation
that you set for yourself every day
you're taking down a peg and that's
gotta like just wear on your soul
where's all right until until you are
that person who's like [ __ ] it right I'm
giving up
so my first my first rock-bottom is when
I decided to start running and I did a
starvation diet and lost a hundred
pounds like so I starved myself what
what precipitated that bottom like what
happened where you were like okay when
the weight started coming back after I
had starved myself down a hundred pounds
all the weight started coming back and
I'll try to get back on the diet that
starvation diet and then it was like
this trap of like like I was burnt I
couldn't do it anymore and I would try
and then I'm like I would binge eat to
where like I knew it was so bad rich
like this gas station had the Krispy
Kreme Doughnuts and then I knew like I
would drive to another gas station
because I knew they had the mrs. Fields
Cookies and then it's like okay I'll
beat myself down so bad like okay I
messed up let me just go ahead and like
push myself down the rest of the stairs
I'll trip down one push myself down the
rest and I would go to like Wendy's like
all right like now I'm just right I'm on
now right like once the seals cracked
like anything goes and then you just
want to make yourself so sick because
I'll be like this is my last time I'm
gonna make myself so sick that I'll
never want to do this again
and I would I would expand so much
overnight from like I don't know maybe
10,000 15,000 calories like I'm talking
about massive loads of food and I've
never get full for some reason I would
get sick but I wouldn't get full and I
wake up the next day and my skin all
over my body would be bruised like it
would hurt to touch my skin and I've
never heard that before like what is
that I don't know I could never find
anything on it it was just like
expansion retaining so much water like
like eating that mini process because I
never ate real food when I binge eat I
would never go to a restaurant you're
not heating fruits and vegetables like
we're even just mashed potatoes and
steak like just like there was like it
would be processing gas station junk
food was the only thing I wanted because
I wanted to sit in my car where was you
know hidden and and another thing like
it sent me into this depressed state to
where like it would usually be on the
weekends like the binging would happen
that I was so terrified of Fridays and
Saturdays like I don't know if there's a
phobia like for Fridays and Saturdays
but I had a phobia like I'm in the music
industry and everybody I know is going
out and they're going to the clubs and
they're enjoying themselves and I'm not
crawled up in my room depressed and
they're going to the clubs to listen to
the music that we make like that we give
them entertainment and I'm just like I'm
scared of the weekend I couldn't wait
for Monday so I could just be accepted
in the one place that I'm good and
that's the office and yeah so so the
shame it was it was terrible and you
never like did you ever veer into eating
disorder territory with you know
throwing up or the bulimia or no I mean
if you're doing starvation stuff that's
sort of tiptoeing around anorexic that
was definitely too soon I went to like
therapist like I was like really trying
to like figure out how to mentally get
over it but I had all the wrong and for
me
and I was like okay no more diets I'm
gonna run
so like Scott walked into my life he was
like I'm gonna stick with you brainer
and yeah like bestfriend type trainer
and he's like Charlie I know there's
something special about you I see it in
you and I know your brain is fried from
all these diets and we're just gonna run
and when he said that it went back to
like my childhood dream there's like an
athlete how could anybody run a marathon
and be fat like when I do this he
challenged me to a marathon I said yes
and we started training and we did a one
marathon Santa Rosa how long did it take
you to train for about 10 months mm-hmm
gained weight during the training during
the training as you came during the
training probably about 10 pounds uh-huh
so you're keeping the same eating habits
and then with all the sort of exercise
output there's the kind of reward
mechanism on top of that well I just ran
eight mile so I can actually eat more
and feel fine about it exactly you're
not addressing exactly habits and the
attitudes around food and it just it
just got worse you know it was appetite
increased and I would wake up every
morning and train I did a full marathon
gained weight and so I'm like okay we're
gonna do another one but let's hold on
hold on let's explore that a little bit
because I think that's news to a lot of
people like the idea like listen if
you're training for a marathon you're
gonna lose weight no matter what exactly
what I thought and what did Scott think
when you actually gained weight I don't
know how he dealt with me because I was
such a victim every day I'm just like
I'm just like in this victim mentality
like what else do you want me to do and
he's having to deal with me and deal
with them late night text messages that
are this long me being depressed and
like because I'm trying it's that what
we were talking about like trying even
harder and still gaining weight right
like so yeah so that's like another
bottom right like what yeah what do you
want like I run a train for a marathon
marathon of Guinea I'm actually getting
bigger so we we said we're gonna do
another one but this time we're going to
do bike riding as well so you're gonna
run another marathon but we're gonna
train on the bike as well she's sort of
like a physical version of a starvation
diet like let's just exhaust you right
let's just like keep your body moving so
much that your metabolism has no choice
but you know lose weight right so what
happened with that gained weight so uh
huh
and that was that was the Silver Comet
marathon in Atlanta and then that was
October and then we're like okay we're
gonna do another America but you to be
fair like you're eating crap right it's
not you're not like I'm trying to like
well I'm dieting kind of like I'm like
every three hours like eat this but then
I would crack their feel wrong
exactly and it would be like one day of
binge eating would beat would would undo
undo six days of like doing good and I
was always hungry and when I cracked it
was just
it'll just be bad so so we did a third
marathon the LA Marathon and this I was
at such a heavy weight I don't know how
I did it like my all my toenails turn
black and fell off I was pounding so
much and like when I run marathons I
don't walk like it's like I see people
walking I'm like I grind like I go hard
but when I look back at pictures of that
marathon I'm like Jesus I was huge
how did I do that it's like man I'm
unbelievable and that is what like at
that moment I went rock bottom rich and
I I didn't think what is the emotional
state of finishing a third marathon and
and continuing to expand and and feeling
like there is no solution accessible for
you to solve this problem he you feel
like there's no more road left what else
can I do like I remember I would um like
I'm like a figure stuff out type of guy
I have my notebook I'm gonna come up
with a game plan it is like I'm going
right back to that like okay what's
worked for me in the past like how do we
do this and boom boom boom and I was I
was being called to nature at this
moment like I was always be called to
nature like just go sit down in nature
and write and think in game play and
then I there was this voice and it was
like Charlie you can't figure this one
out in your notebook I closed the
notebook and I thought about it and I
was like maybe I need to go on a journey
I was like I was like maybe I need to go
on a journey and I remember in the next
couple of days I woke up and the room
started spinning like like something was
wrong spinning like not me like
hallucinating but like I'm consciously
like I wake up turn my head up to the
ceiling look up and I'm like wow the
room spinning this can't be good how
long is it gonna last I'm sitting there
15 20 seconds later it stops and then I
get out of bed go pick up my shoes boom
pass out I wake up I'm on the floor I'm
like yeah this is good this isn't good
like something's actually wrong here and
how long after that that LA Marathon was
this this was this was like eight months
mm-hmm and what year are we talking
about this is we're now last year oh
well this is just last year yeah this is
last November mmm and boom
brain tumor that's what caused me to
pass out brain tumor wrapped around my
left optic nerve wrapped around my
coronary artery and doctor said it could
start corroding the top of my spinal
cord and that was I thought I was rock
bottom before but then when you feel
like it's over
like like I'm gonna die I realize what
that whole you need to go on a journey
they meant it's amazing that that was
just one year ago and that the trigger
occurred on the heels of you kind of
making this promise to yourself or this
decision that you were gonna go on this
journey mm and you were rewarded with
that decision with this unbelievable
news best thing that happened you have
to take a hospital to the how did you
find out that you had a brain tumor in
mind yeah yeah yeah and so what's the
prognosis at that time what's the doctor
telling you you're gonna have to do
medication um or chemotherapy medication
body acted a little funny with it they
wanted to put me on higher levels and
they said that would affect my heart
like my heart valves like they said well
this medication has one downside you
know this is the same brain tumor that
Tony Robbins had when he was my um a
pituitary tumor so it throws everything
in your body off the pituitary gland and
all the hormones and that's when the
journey started and I was I was I didn't
want to listen to people and I moved to
California I didn't tell my family or my
business partners that I was moving I
said I'm going for a few weeks
they knew you had cancer though but they
have cancer
it wasn't cancer but brain tumor it was
it was it was benign
thank God I see that or not not okay all
right so they knew something was wrong
they knew I was in a bad place and I
said I'm gonna go to California for some
meetings you know Oh like I'm going out
there for a few weeks I knew I was gone
but I didn't want a big like going away
like people scared none of that so I
went for a couple weeks and they said no
meetings are going great out here you
know like I think I'm gonna stay a
couple more weeks and by Christmas they
were like have you moved I'm like you
know what I think I think it's good for
me because you know it's really healthy
out there and I decided to go vegan and
this is another thing so I went being in
and I gained 20 pounds hmm
I had no idea what I was doing mm-hmm I
was eating it edgy Grill every day
getting like hamburgers and stuff and I
was like well if I go vegan it's
impossible that I'll gain weight like
this is going to be the answer
yeah not true especially the this day
and age with so many yummy you know non
animal versions of your favorite junk
food yeah and I had got back up I'd
gained 20 more pounds got up to about
260 270 again and this was March and
April this is you know like less than a
year ago less than a year ago and I was
like okay let me stop everything I tried
to leave my company in April they
wouldn't let me they said Charlie just
go figure out whatever you need to
figure out we'll be here when you're
done and I just went on a journey to
learn but this impulse to like leave
your company and go on this journey and
the processing of you know having a
brain tumor and your inability to kind
of you know
manage your own physical being I mean
where is this where is this leaving you
emotionally I mean obviously there's a
lot of turmoil in your life for you to
just up and go to California by yourself
and not really feel comfortable enough
to be honest about what it is that
you're you're actually doing or seeking
like where is your head at this point
are you like having this reassembly of
what's important to you or you know what
is occurring to you at that at that
moment at that moment I was I was gone I
was going out of business like I was
gone like it wasn't like you're really
like you're you don't care about all
this other stuff that you thought was
important nothing matter anymore
nothing mattered money business the cool
winning Grammys all that stuff just
didn't matter I've I had to reconnect
with the dream and I said I'm gonna be
an athlete I'm gonna fix this once and
for sure I mean once and for all and I'm
gonna do everything I'm gonna do an
Ironman I'm going to change my eating I
I had this I boiled it down to something
very simple and I needed simplicity
because I had all this data from dieting
like everything every three hours and
they just don't eat this like and I was
like I need something simple and that's
what I liked about vegan but then I
needed like even more simple than vegan
I needed even more rules to just like
just do this and I I came up with this
in my head um I said if what they're
saying is true you are what you eat and
I'm dying is what I'm eating dead or
alive and when I thought about it like
that I was like okay I started asking
myself questions oil okay that's
probably dead so that's probably dead
banana oh that's a life potato alive and
and that because you dead or alive diet
100% like like even just because
something vegan like it was like I got
rid of the oil I got rid of the salt I
got rid of just I just we're gonna eat
like fruits and vegetables that are like
living all day
well not 100% um like probably like 60
70 percent and the brain tumor started
shrinking my hormones in my body leveled
out like like the food caused it because
because because with the pituitary tumor
it's all hormones and all I was eating
my whole life was me because I was doing
ketogenic diets like most of the diets I
were doing were like ketogenic diets and
I mean John's meat Dom almost no
vegetables like very rarely and
processed foods when I binge and like
diet sodas and all that type of stuff
and I know that's what caused a brain
tumor
yeah just Jack your endocrine system
yeah threw everything off body just
deformed he node formed the tumor and
then when I started eating food that was
a lot started shrinking doctors are like
wow right like how long did that take
this is what did you first notice that
it was shrinking so I haven't taken my
medicine in almost five months and my
hormones coming down lower like like the
prolactin level is like super high and
it's coming all the way down and this
shrinking and like my the testosterone
is leveling out on its aunt like no
medicine like doctors were prescribing
me like testosterone stuff prescribed me
stuff for that like the hormones like
that's what controls it and I started
just like eating living foods and a lot
of raw food yeah like a lot like I eat
like George smells like I eat like six
oranges a day like in an hour
like because because I'm exercising a
lot to him training for the Ironman so
that's amazing so what did the doctors
say when you went back in and they were
seeing these kinds of results in you and
I mean we're using one to say like did
they tell you like it's okay for you to
go off the medication or were you just
saying I'm not going to do that or like
how did that
go down I made my own rules there wasn't
much conversation but were they
surprised that you were balancing out in
that way and that there was some
evidence of shrinking yes mm-hmm
totally is that like normal as like does
that have I mean the idea that food
could have an impact on the growth or
regression of of a tumorous growth in
your brain it's probably you know
something that a lot of people would
tell you can't be the case mm-hmm I mean
I'm not a doctor but I mean what were
these doctors telling you that they they
didn't want to talk much like it it was
in and out like kind of absurd like I'd
go in and I get my blood work done and
it's like everything looks good
that's it moves like that's the bedside
manner they don't want to talk hmm what
do you think that's about it's just
that's the system that's set up to see
as many people as possible
yeah I mean as doctors you like who were
your doctors out like Cedars or
someplace like I don't want to I don't
want to cause a fury but good doctors
you know one here one in Atlanta mm-hmm
so you're here doing this self-styled
Dead or Alive diet the tumors shrinking
I mean first of all what what inspired
you to as somebody who has done a
million different diets like what was it
that got you excited about trying this
which sounds like it's something that
you hadn't tried yet I just needed
something that made sense I just needed
like I'm starting to just boil things
down in my life like what makes sense
and when I would watch these
documentaries on veganism and stuff and
I was like that makes sense and the oil
and everything I was like okay like let
me get rid of anything that's dead and I
just
I do good with rules like I don't see it
on that like it's like it's easy for me
mm-hmm because it's it's like I used to
celebrate food now I like celebrate
taking my shirt off at the beach for the
first time in my life I celebrate this
morning you know I ran eight and a half
miles and it's my fifth day of working
out without a rest day and it's like wow
I crushed it and one of my fastest
speeds at almost under a nine minute
pace mm-hmm and like I used to run like
when I did my marathons I was like a
12:45 it's like you know like it was
like wow like that's what I'm
celebrating now so people are like is
this hard for you like no like it's
actually easy it's way easier than a
diet because the relationship when I
look at her arms like now I look at it
like wow like this is live this is alive
like I wish like food had like a label
on it that had like the level of energy
that the food puts off instead of like
people thinking about like food gives
you energy like an energy bar like that
has zero energy like it's a it's a dead
thing that can sit on a shelf for four
years like that's not energy you know
like let's look at energy differently
this thing is alive that means there's
frequencies and energies coming off of
it we're like something that can sit on
a shelf for four years that's like very
low frequency energy
yeah the Chi that you know you're gonna
get all like whoo New Age now on it but
it's true it's like yeah what is what it
I mean everything is energy right so
what is the energy what vibration is
this thing you know vibrating so you
already know it's in here somewhere it's
in here this phone I carry this guy with
yeah Einstein Einstein bobblehead it
actually doesn't bother I wish it
wobbled I don't know what it does but
quantum physics energy
he described everything he described how
me and you met energy the entanglement
like it's actually all backed up by
science and I've been studying it George
introduced me to a quantum physicist oh
yeah I think you told me when we met you
were rushing off because you were going
to meet this guy yeah yeah that's right
when I know about this
so all these crazy things started having
in my life and I didn't feel comfortable
talking to people about them but when I
cleaned up my diet it was like it was
like I had superpowers and I like didn't
want to tell people because I didn't
want to seem weird or like hippy or
whatever like I'm just a good old
southern boy and but I had these
superpowers like I could think of
somebody and then they'll call me and
then like there was this girl who I
hadn't seen in 10 years and I went
searching for our Instagram and I
couldn't find her and then the next day
she liked my page and direct messaged me
and I was like oh like and then this
started happening a lot and then I was
like I thought like I said I said to my
friend I was like I want I want to help
Oprah with her health and then tomorrow
I have a meeting with Oprah's producers
mmm like this is like happening fast and
as II it's like it's easy for me to do
now and I had all these questions on how
this is happening and the quantum
physicist explained it to me and he told
me about this study where they took
human DNA the the military did this
study they took human DNA put it in a
dish and they have the instruments study
the energy coming off of the dish they
took that human being put him in another
part of the building had him watch like
an emotional video that like made him
like emotional and the DNA changed the
energy changed it increased the DNA that
had been extracted that was in the other
room was being impacted by the stimulus
that the human being was exposed to yes
and out of sight what quantum physics
says and this isn't me this isn't me
but come on some physics says the guy's
telling you is is that atom particles
can be in two places at one time and
when they did that's definitely a fact
they've done those studies double smart
holes are like on opposite sides of the
coast and are being impacted by each
other exactly and that's how I mean you
got connected I said I want to meet rich
roll a kid dm's me and introduces us
just like that I said I want to help
Oprah boom I have a meeting with her
producers like like I think of somebody
they DM me because the particles are we
are entangled and I started studying the
the the quantum physics just to make
sure I wasn't crazy
and it all says that yeah like your body
is clean you're eating living things
that have high frequency so your antenna
goes further than when you were eating
bad things you got rid of all the
negative things in your life you cleaned
up and your antenna just reaches further
than it used to
I was like that makes sense I get it
thank you answer I can I can vouch for
that you know and it is a weird thing
because you don't want to come off as
sounding crazy but I can certainly
attest to the fact that that cleaning up
my diet and starting to eat living
things had a much larger impact on my
life than just slimming down and even
beyond just being able to be successful
as an athlete like it changed everything
about Who I am and how I interact with
the world and my daughter just turned 14
so we had a little birthday dinner for
her the other night and we were going
through like old photos you know like
old photos from like when she was a baby
and you know I was never more badly
obese like yourself I wasn't 300 pounds
but I was like a hefty you know I was
like 50 55 pounds overweight mm-hmm and
so I was we were scrolling back and I
saw some of those pictures from like
2004 2005 and my daughter is looking at
them they're like who is that you know
it doesn't look like the same person and
I even said to my wife like man like
that was a challenged time
she was like yeah it wasn't fun mm-hmm
and that hurt to hear her say that
and she wasn't saying that because she
wasn't physically attracted to me she
was saying that because I was carrying
around like a heavy energy mmm I had
nothing to do with what the scale said
like a certain density right and my
journey with cleaning up my diet is
actually a journey of self-discovery and
self-actualization that begins with the
foods that are on your plate right
that's the opening portal like that's
right that's the opening to the cave
that you're like walking into or right
and what gets people through the door is
the idea of like oh like look at
Charlie's before-and-after pictures like
that's what I want
yeah I'm struggling but what it delivers
is so much more like the weight is
nothing compared to the impact that it
can have on fundamentally every aspect
of how you live your life how you see
yourself your relationship with yourself
your relationship with others and it is
a very esoteric thing and I'm glad that
there's a there's a quantum physicist
out there that can like apply some
science to it but my own personal
anecdotal evidence is simply that I am
aligning myself with a higher frequency
mm-hmm with which you know this earth or
this environment in which we inhabit is
is vibrating like it's yeah and you're
you're in tune with that in a new and
different way which sets you on a
different trajectory for your life the
idea like I'm not sitting here having a
podcast with you and writing the but
doing all the things that I do because I
vision board it and I wrote it out and
said this is my plan and my goal that
I'm going after these things have
occurred as a result of my commitment
always trying to improve myself mmm
right and that journey towards the
center towards the heart has deposited
me in this place despite myself well
which which would have chosen something
else for myself my ego would have chosen
a different path because it doesn't have
the
at a vision that this life force has mmm
right I think I described that very well
but I think you get where I'm coming
100% and you're on a very similar
journey with that and I've seen this in
other people I've seen this with people
in sobriety who get who get cleaned from
drugs and alcohol and I've seen it with
people who have stepped in to the Dead
or Alive diet for lack of a better
phrase eating
I mean it's essentially a whole food
plant-based diet tipping towards like a
lot of raw foods right it's essentially
what you're doing and I've seen the
lights go on in people in a way that you
you would not imagine that extends so
far beyond the waistline it's insane
there was a second part that I think
some of the viewers might like when I
said simple rules
I had another simple rule other than the
Dead or Alive and it was eat when I'm
hungry stop when I'm full like literally
if I'm hungry there aren't rules like
the body is smarter then we ever could
be like it's so beautifully designed and
miraculously designed when it says it's
hungry I eat and I only stop you know my
frigerator with like low calorie dense
things I was like oh like sweet potatoes
I hate them all day like baked potatoes
I need them all day put a whole bunch of
sauce on when I learned that a pound
when I looked at calories differently I
stopped counting calories I said oh how
many calories are in a pound of
something that's all I want to know mmm
because if I think of like me filling up
like if I ate two pounds three pounds or
something I'll be stuffed so I was like
okay if I ate a pound of strawberries
it's like a hundred and forty five
calories per pound or if I ate a pound
of cashews there's 3,500 calories a
pound if I eat a pound of sweet potatoes
it's 350 calories per pound if I ate a
pound of baked potatoes I mean uh potato
chips it's like three thousand so I'm
like oh let me just fill my stomach up
and always
be full and if I'm always full I never
have to dye it again
and I'm always full that is my ID I did
my whole life where I was like restrict
stick within these calories
now I naturally stick within the
calories because I only eat calorie low
calorie dense full mm-hm
like if it's under 500 calories a pound
oh I'm stuffing myself with it right low
calorie dense but nutrient dense
you know chef AJ she speaks about this a
lot I can turn you on to some videos
where she breaks that down beautifully
but that's exactly what you're doing
you're eating foods that are really high
in fiber that you're getting full but
you're not in lots of water yes so it's
like you know either you can you can
have a teaspoon of oil yes or you can
eat like two baked potatoes right
exactly you know what I mean exam two
this idea of rules like I work really
well rules too and and I think it's
important to have rules not too many
rules but enough rules that it takes the
decision fatigue out of how you're going
to approach your day and that's true of
me in how I approach my professional
career it's true of how I approach my
training like when I'm not working with
my coach and I don't know what I'm
supposed to do that day then who knows
what I'm gonna do and I wake up and I'm
like well I could do this but maybe I
should do that well then I'll move this
around so I can do that like all these
decisions you have to make as opposed to
oh I look at the calendar and like it's
a two-hour bike today that's what I do
there's no there's no debate there's no
whatever it is that's the way it is and
similarly with respect to diet and
nutrition you know there are a few rules
it's like I don't eat any it is a dead
or a live thing like I don't eat any
animal products pretty basic rule it's
really simple it's sort of like in
sobriety I don't use drugs and alcohol
no matter what like that's just the rule
you don't break right so that's
fundamental rule number one no animal
products and then you go down the scale
of like you know eating eating these
plant foods as close to their natural
state as possible
there's gradations within that but you
just kind of approach it from that
fundamental perspective it doesn't have
to be that complicated
mm-hmm and it's freed up so much mental
space for me not having to make food
decisions anymore because every day used
to be like there was fear of every meal
every meal was scary to think about like
Oh Lord like I'm hungry I have to eat
like oh my god like uh and then we'd be
planning meals and celebrating meals and
then like it was always everyday
multiple multiple big decisions
especially when you're scared of food
it's like it's like I talked about in
the video like I envy people who like
addicted to drugs because like you can
call Turkey a drug and never have to
deal with it again with food like you
have to deal with it every day and when
you're terrified of food that's when it
gets scary to make decisions well one of
the things you said earlier is that you
weren't when you were struggling with
your dietary proclivities and choices
and trying out all these different
programs unsuccessfully you weren't
dealing with your core issues you were
like pruning the the branches but you
weren't getting to the soil and the
roots right so so I take it now
fundamentally you know diet choices
aside that you are kind of dealing with
the roots so what and what are those
issues and what is that journey towards
you know you know reckoning with that
been like first thing was from a child I
wanted to be an athlete and I had to
address that it's interesting sorry to
interrupt but it's interesting that with
all your success as a music manager I
mean most people would look at that like
Grammys you know successful making money
going to crazy party whatever like cares
about the athlete thing man like all the
athletes want to be what you know doing
what you're doing right like you're fine
let it go and and I let it go I let that
whole life go and it was easy for me to
like like some of my friends are like is
that hard for you to walk away and I'm
like no like I know I can never truly be
successful if I don't have my health
when you're looking at your death it's
like what does this mean anyways and I
would always have these dreams only only
one it's not like a bad dream but it's a
reoccurring dream with a negative
feeling of I died before I got to
realize what it was like to be fit like
that's my fear like I want to know what
it's like to have a six-pack or to be
able to like not be afraid to look in
the mirror and if that was always my
underlying root it's like I made lots of
money but now I live with four remains
and I don't mind like I'm like living my
dream and money and impressing people
and I could be like honest and humble
like I'm a successful guy but like I
know that no money is coming in so I
need to live with roommates mm-hmm what
am I afraid of like I'm chasing my dream
I'm gonna be an athlete and I'm gonna
I'm gonna do this Ironman and then me
and my best friend we're going biked
across America and allow people to bike
with us like with this interactive map
where people can see where we are and
then I'm gonna do a relay race across
America and it's gonna start July 4th in
New York and it's going to be a torch
and we're all going to get this torch
across America and it's going to be
America connecting together in different
people like me and you and other people
who want to be like us I want to want to
do better with their life and
reinventing their life they're all going
to get this torch across America and
we're going to be connected and that's
my dream I love marketing I'm a good
businessman but now I can apply my gift
to like okay we value a dollar so much
like we get we like people jump through
hoops for money like that's what they
think about all day and then I'm like a
human life is more valuable than a
dollar but like I talked about in the
beginning like a million dollars I did
that whatever
now I wanna help transform a million
lives that's the new type of millionaire
like in there's people like you that
exist that are doing it naturally you
know like I'm you inspired me now I want
to do it and I'm gonna reach my hand
back and then there's just gonna be more
and more of us and I'm gonna take what I
learned with marketing I look at it like
God wanted me to go do the hip hop thing
so I can learn how to influence culture
like he just sent me sent me over there
go learn how to market really good in
influence culture so when you come over
here to do good for people and be of
service to people you're ready to go and
I can mark it like the best of them and
make movements worldwide with what I
know but instead of doing it for money
like before I was just a consumer now
I'm a provider mmm you know me just
being able to tell my story I can help
some it's an amazing thing like George
like Chris Collins said like we can talk
into this microphone and this internet
thing it can go like like we're gonna
like say something into here with just
our mouth and somebody's life which is a
valuable thing is going to be saved like
yeah it's common kind of like
electricity is coming that's an amazing
thing that like like we can't forget how
amazing this internet thing is like
because somebody's listening and their
life is gonna change like like when when
I hear your story help change my life
somebody's gonna hear my like somebody's
life that's a valuable thing like
somebody is depressed and thinking of
suicide or addicted to drugs and gonna
kill them so like we can just use our
mouth to top it's just an amazing thing
well I get I get crazy emails every
single day from people that are that are
impacted profoundly by the messages and
the stories told by that guests that are
sitting in the chair that you're sitting
in right now so I'm familiar with that
and I think we're only tapping the
surface of what's possible we're in the
infancy of this Internet age and it just
feels good to be part of
solution for people in whatever small
way that we can and look there's nothing
more powerful than an extraordinary
story well told you know and your story
is your story is very powerful and so
that's why I wanted to have you here to
be able to share it because I think it
does hold within at the potential energy
to catalyze change in other people who
feel stuck who feel like they've tried
every diet they can't see their way
through it they're ready to give up
whether it's drugs or alcohol or
relationships or food or gambling or
shopping or whatever it is you know the
idea that somebody has pulled themselves
up from the abyss from that vicious
cycle of being unable to unable to to
you know be the person that they always
want it to be to now be meeting that you
know full-on with the embrace that that
that that you have at the moment is
empowering and it's infectious I think
you know it's as infectious as as a
terrible virus you know in the most
positive way
yeah and what's great about your story
is that it's continuing to unfold it's a
story that's still being told I mean
this was nine months ago when the brain
tumour thing came and you decided to get
serious about your food your
relationship with food I mean that's not
that long ago I'm looking I look at you
now you don't look anything like those
pictures I mean you've lost what like a
hundred pounds or something like that so
I've lost a total of 125 25 pounds but
in the past seven eight months 80 mm-hmm
that's crazy that's not very long time
and I think what's interesting also
about what has allowed it allowed you to
make it work this time is something that
I've heard on this podcast before with
with my friend Josh love Johnny he you
know he's a guy who lost a tremendous
amount of weight but a real fundamental
sea change for him was when he stopped
thinking about and focusing on what the
scale said and he fundamentally changed
his relationship with food and he
started considering himself to be an
athlete like it's not about weight loss
it's about how do I become the athlete
that I always want
to be and the more he put his focus on
that and less on like what is you know
what's my weight or what is my waistline
look like instead of it but rather like
how can I be a better runner how can I
get faster you know what do I need to do
it almost was like a release valve that
took the pressure off because suddenly
it wasn't a ticking clock it's just this
is your life now
right and I see a similar kind of
approach or kind of shift in
decision-making in perspective in
yourself definitely and there was a
little trick that I found out in
business and finally applying that to my
health was it's just easier to go bold
like wait saying you're gonna wake up
and run every day this is so much harder
than saying I'm gonna do an Ironman like
going bold is easier because now like
when people introduce you to somebody
like oh he's training for an Ironman
they would never say oh he wakes up and
runs every day like it ultimately
becomes you that's why I like being
vegan for me was easy because it's like
I'm accountable like I'm vegan everybody
knows it now like my friends my family
so going big and bold is easier and when
I think about you it's like man you do
superhuman things and I bet that's I bet
doing those superhuman things is easier
like because you're just mentally ready
to go bigger then just saying I'm gonna
wake up and run everyday like like well
that doesn't mean anything to me exactly
and and what is the accountability
factor with that like you need a goal
that scares you enough though so that
you how you hold yourself accountable
mm-hmm and I think there's something
also to be said for the sort of exotic
nature of it like the more the the
bolder the goal the less crowded the
space right it's like everybody's kind
of clamoring around like we're running a
5k or a 10k less people a marathon even
less people you know
an Ironman and then you know upwards
upwards you go and it gets scarier as
you notch it up which increases the
level of self-accountability
mm-hmm but it's also exciting you know
that's what gets you out of bed in the
morning like pump for your day part of
that is fear a healthy fear and part of
it is is the thrill of not knowing
exactly what's gonna happen yes right
yeah but why do you like I want to
explore a little bit like why you felt
the need to walk away from your career
completely because I'm sure people would
say look you want to do that you want to
like eat raw food and you want to like
train for an Ironman that's great well
you don't have to quit your job it's
like you know a lot of people do Iron
Man's you know they still they still
work like why did you feel I know the
answer to this but I want to hear you
say it like I want I'm interested in how
you're gonna articulate this like why
was it important for you to really like
draw this line in the sand and make this
dramatic like basic pronouncement about
how you were shifting your life this is
why your podcast is so good yes good
questions that are not easy to answer um
I knew that every single thing I was
doing in my life was wrong
literally everything like I was a good
person but my actions like give me an
example I
I made a choice and the choice will set
you down a road and when you're somebody
like me who is loyal and is committed
like it leads down long long roads and I
made a choice when I was eight that I
was gonna go into business and that's
where it started it was like okay III
put something under the rug I just swept
something under the rug that should not
have been swept under the rug I should
have dealt with motional II emotionally
subconsciously it was always there want
to be an athlete I want to be fit I was
the chubby kid let me I should have
addressed that then and then I made the
decision I'm gonna get into hip-hop and
hip-hop was amazing to me hip-hop was a
love-hate relationship changed my life
made me extremely successful allowed me
to you know take care of my parents and
take care of my family and you know
myself and but it was tough as well it
was I had I had an artist get shot and
killed at my studio um I was breaking up
a fight one day and bullets flew right
past me and we were all running 2 Chainz
got shot at in San Francisco another one
of my artists young Dolph he got shot at
a hundred times in Charlotte and then he
got shot four times here in LA about a
month ago like you were around when
these shootings are going on I was
around in one of them but it's it's that
it's that like I live the real like I'm
a very soft-spoken guy just an
entrepreneur you know hip-hop I knew
like like I said like I always had a
gift to see what was coming around the
corner of culture and when I was young I
was like this hip-hop thing is going to
be big and now it's the biggest genre in
the world
the number-one grossing genre in the
entire world and I saw that years ago
and that's why I got into the business
and it was good and it was bad and I had
to change everything in my life if I
wanted to live and I did and I was I had
the courage and I wasn't scared and I
knew I'll know I know how to make money
I'll go make money again I'll jump into
a pool and I'll learn how to swim and
people will want to help me along the
way and like right now yeah scary I
don't make any money I'm gonna be fine
I'm not worried like if I just do what's
right for my dreams and if I help people
I have more blessings than than I ever
thought I would have from hell but like
like it's that's the truth I mean again
that's my experience and and the money
will come it's probably not going to
come the way you think it might or when
you think it might or in the amounts
that you think it might but it doesn't
matter because you'll be taken care of
as long as your focus is on service and
self-care right taking care of yourself
making sure that your your actions are
in alignment with your values that you
are being true to this mission this that
you feel is is really like this
instinctual call for how you need to be
in the world and express yourself and
sharing that freely of yourself in
service to other people in a real
profound and fundamental way everything
else will get taken care of like that's
a promise I know it even you know I know
it yeah you know yeah and it was you
know that's it happened for me it took a
freaking long time you know like I did
go through a lot but ultimately all of
those experiences have value and make it
all the more meaningful to me now right
mm-hmm
and for some reason you're being called
to serve in this way and you could into
it or construe your brain tumor as this
ultimate
kind of reckoning moment of trying to
get you to finally pay attention to this
thing that you've been ignoring your
whole life that is obviously so
important to you that's right and you're
in the nascent early stages of wrestling
with and trying to figure out how to
move forward with this in a productive
way and it's cool to see yeah man yeah
when's the Iron Man March third New
Zealand yeah that's good I did a half
iron coming up quick here it's coming up
quick I got it like seven weeks left of
training my intense training so I'm
feeling good
I still got some weight to drop I still
got a gut you know that's all right man
I must for your life yeah yeah exactly
you know that race will come and go
whatever's hot going to happen is gonna
happen but it's not gonna impact like
how you're living moving forward right
I'm so excited because it's it's like
I'm gonna allow people to like go on the
journey with me and I'm like I'm no
superhero like you know in my video I
talked about like charlie rocket like
you you know like the superhero I relate
to in Georgia nother story
oh that I relate to is it's kind of like
spider-man cuz he was like one of us you
know like like spy Spiderman was just a
regular guy and that's how I am like I
like some superhero like I'm just like
you know a regular regular guy but like
I wanted to be able to find my inner
superhero that would save my life
because there's two of me there's the
there's there's there's the guy who has
the flaws but then there's this like
inner superhero and I gave him a name
Charlie rocket and and every morning
like I earned into him when I'm working
out because it's so fun to be a
superhero and I had just came up with
this recently like this was like four or
five months ago like and I'm like I'm
gonna be a superhero when I work out I
brought mine I brought my headband you
got a charlie Rockets superhero headband
oh yeah yeah there it is image like a
kamikaze I made it I had my friend
printed up and then I have this
seamstress stitch it together
but like if you look on there's like
little rocket emojis uh-huh and then I
put this on in the morning and then I
put my dad is like it's either that or
you're like it you work at Benihana and
then it's like oh like like and and it's
interesting when I when I bike and run
down the boardwalk in the morning like
people like see my energy because I'm
having fun like everybody's usually in
their own zone but like like people
high-five me and like people are getting
to know me now like in Santa Monica in
Venice and they ask me what's your name
I'm like charlie rocket and then the
next morning they'll be like rocket you
know and it's just it's just fun to
transform into the superhero that I want
to be and I think everybody should
practice that like like you know how on
podcast so I asked like what's your
inner animal spirits you know and I'm
like what's your inner emoji spirit like
I'm the rocket like you know I want to
be a rocket like a rocket takes off real
slow but then it gets fast mm-hmm like
once it and but it just keeps going and
then at some point it just gets fast and
my weight-loss journey my fitness
journey started off real slow but I'm
about to get fast because I'm about to
hit that that's 60 like also because the
resistance is very high initially
there's so much force pressing down on
you to prevent you from you know
reaching you know cruising altitude
right but as you start to you know get
higher and higher up the resistance is
less and less and less until you're in
space and the world is the universe is
just open to you right that's right
without very little force you can go a
very long way right but I like that
story and it's it reminds me of the iron
cowboy I loved had on the podcast a
couple times you know I don't know if
you listen to those episodes people who
are listening he's the guy who did 50
iron mans in 50 states in 50 days
and he's the iron cowboy and he has a
very similar relationship with who the
iron cowboy is versus James Lawrence
right it's like the iron cowboy is his
superhero you know doppelganger and when
he wakes up in the morning and goes out
to train or he goes out into the world
he adorns the trappings of this
superhero character and then he inhabits
that character right it's like it's like
this thing there's there's James the
flawed human being the normal guy or
whatever and then there's the hat and
the cape that he puts on to go be this
person and achieve these amazing things
and there's something about that
relationship that seems to be like a
springboard for achieving things that
you didn't think you you're capable of
achieving right totally yeah because I
mean how long ago would the idea for you
of tackling an Ironman have seemed just
ridiculous and impossible nine months
ago I made the decision to do it eight
months ago it would have seemed
ridiculous and then when I made up my
mind
and I wanted to ask you a question about
this like mastering your mindset because
I still deal with like smaller thinking
even though I'm doing something bold
like two months after starting to bike I
was so ignorant to what was possible
that like I was like I'm gonna do 112
mile bike ride today uh-huh and I didn't
you did yeah and I'm like because I was
ignorant like I was just like but
emotionally and mentally perhaps there
was something inside of you that need it
you needed to prove to yourself that
that that like before you even invested
yourself too much in this let's just see
if like I can bang this out right not
the smartest thing in the world but
emotionally there was some reason why
you needed to do that for yourself right
and it wasn't even hard but it was like
I said oh 12 yeah and then I started
telling all my friends I'm gonna do it
and then I knocked it out and I was done
and now like where I kind of struggle
just on some days is I just think too
small I'm like if I just thought bigger
like what just be will my body magically
like yesterday was my body magically
struggling with the 40 miles just
because I said I'm gonna do 40 miles
like why was the hundred and twelve the
same difficulty as the 40 like you've
done like super extreme things I get
what you're saying though you know when
you decide like this is what I'm trying
to achieve for the day and you put a cap
on that then it always seems like you
struggle to the end of that whereas if
you would double that
then what would with that first half of
it just seemed easy like there is
something to that I think in terms of of
how you envision yourself
and your your ultimate like capabilities
and and and potential as an athlete or
as a human being I kind of look at it
like through the through the lens or the
context of a big wave surfer so if
you've never surfed before or maybe you
can surf a one foot wave and do it with
some level of mastery that doesn't mean
that you're gonna go out to Mavericks
or you know to the North Shore of Hawaii
and drop in on a 20-foot wave that would
not be smart it's possible that you're
capable of handling that but there is a
whole lot of work that has to take place
in between you know that one foot wave
and tackling that 20 foot wave because
the people that are great at those huge
waves the Laird Hamilton's they inch up
to it very gradually you know the one
foot wave to the one-and-a-half to the
two to the three so but by the time
they're dropping in on a 50-foot wave
they've served a forty five and a half
foot and a 40 foot they've been doing
that for a year so it doesn't seem that
different becomes more accessible and I
think in the context of being an
endurance athlete it's not a one-year
plan like it's you know it basically
takes about five years I think to really
develop some level of mastery in
endurance and ultra endurance and within
that five year period
you're gradually increasing your volume
with your runs and your and your rides
and stuff like that and I'm sure you
would you know over the course of
season as those rides get longer and
longer it used to be excruciating to
ride your bike longer than two hours
like oh my god I'm going insane like
what do I do with myself I you know it's
like I got to get off this bike by the
end of the season as you're ramping up
and getting ready for something like
Ironman you're on your bike five six
seven hours and you're like oh just two
more hours on the bike I've been on six
already like that ain't nothing but a
thing like time bends you know back to
the quantum physics of it all it's it's
a relative thing it's your relationship
with that period of time shifts based
upon your proficiency that's right and
so I think as you as you as you immerse
yourself more and more and more yes you
set higher goals for yourself yes you
you remove those caps but I think there
is something to be said for doing it in
a in a kind of responsible manner so
that you don't hurt yourself do you know
what I mean right so yeah maybe you can
do 50 irons in 50 states in 50 days I'm
not gonna tell CEO Charlie he can't but
you probably can't do it tomorrow right
okay that's all I'm saying
definitely yeah so so let's talk a
little bit about the service aspect of
this like you're on this personal
journey for yourself becoming an athlete
mm-hmm but where does this idea of like
okay I'm not a music manager anymore I
want to share my story like and and
you've alluded to like this torch thing
relay yeah you and all this other kind
of stuff like this is news to me like
tell me like in your marketing genius
you know men are like how this is
unfolding for you so it all is
stimulated by me wanting to have a
community like I moved out to California
and not gonna lie like I'm pretty lonely
like because I'm very protective of my
energy now like who I'm around and I'm
not like a super social like networking
type guy so I'm just gonna build the
community that I wish existed
my life like I'm gonna do awesome things
put that out to the world and then the
awesome people
I want to attract will just come to me
and I'm like if I go big I'm gonna
attract the big people like I'm gonna
attract the people who want it like I
want to bike with you like I'm prepared
to go by myself across the country like
that's fine
but I know if I put that out to the
world then people are gonna be like man
I want to do some of it with you like
I'll do the first hundred miles or I'll
do the first thousand miles with you and
I just want to surround myself I want a
community I want friends who think like
me
who talk like me and I figured the best
way of doing that is if I if I do it if
I just lead and everybody will come and
I want to do these things to let people
know that you know like what we talked
about like my story isn't over yet like
that's the thing like we all feel that
way you know like you didn't come this
far just to come this far you know how
like like that's the thing and and I
just I want to like I heard this
motivational speaker his name is Jeremy
Anderson he was given this analogy
between a caterpillar and a butterfly
and he said the caterpillar is ugly
because the caterpillar is just a
consumer and he said the butterfly is
beautiful because it's of service to the
earth it transplants the pollen and Mike
trees get planted because of the
butterfly and the caterpillar just eats
stuff I'm like wow the butterfly is
beautiful it's doing something for the
world and I've always wanted to be you
know attractive and I figured like I
figured if I give that makes me more
attractive like I want a wife you know
like you have you know I wanna I want a
beautiful family like you have and I
don't feel any of that has come into my
life yet because I wasn't who I was
supposed to be so I transform
and now I'm gonna put out and then all
the right people are gonna walk right
into my life
the lighthouse done lighthouse that's
the lighthouse the lighthouse doesn't
move around up and down the shore mmm
looking for looking for a crowd it just
stays right where it is right
that's what's the beacon out like that
that's the goal
well I'm excited for you dude anything
cool yeah it's cool it's cool to see you
on this journey and and I like that you
know I like that the quantum physics
spiritual component to this because
there's more play than we can see and we
tend to think as human beings that that
our senses are attuned enough that we
can perceive the world exactly as it is
and I think we don't appreciate the
extent to which that is a very false and
limited assumption and you know your
energy I'm sure is very different one
thing I wanted to ask you about is like
what is so what's going on with like
your homeboys back home and like did you
just like go off the radar to them are
like where where are they with like your
life changes they wrote me on there on
there like a like cuz I remember when I
when I told 2 Chainz I was like I was
like this isn't my practice life this is
the one he said that really stuck with
him when I said that like this isn't my
practice life and when I told him what I
want to do like in the roots like I want
to be an athlete they were just like
yeah go for her like you know like we're
disappointed that you know like we're
not gonna be you know a part of your
life of that like I separated from the
business but you know we're friends and
brothers and I love I love them to death
and you know they still have my mind
they don't have my hands but they have
my mind and my mind is actually gonna be
better for them now than it ever was
before and I can help them mark it and
help them come up with great ideas and
it's nice being in a position where I'm
not asking for anything in return
like I'm mentoring like 30 different
people right now
just and I'm like wild like this feels
amazing like to like help somebody and
not ask anything in return oh man I
think I could get used to this yeah and
I never experienced that everything was
always about money mm-hmm but yeah so in
the context of mentoring people you know
a good way that I always kind of like to
close these these conversations down is
to talk a little bit about you know what
you're you know what what you say to
somebody who is stuck who's in that
place where you were in that vicious
cycle like you tried all these diets you
couldn't find your way out you're
running your but you're gaining weight
you go vegan you gain weight like how do
you speak to that person who's in that
place and how do you speak to these
people that you're mentoring to kind of
kickstart them into a new way of
thinking and behaving okay this is a
conversation I had with a young lady who
lives in Louisiana I was helping her and
I told her that I told I told her that
she was put on this earth for a reason
and she's she's she's a Christian and
she believes in God and I told her you
God put you on this earth for a reason
and that's your that's your purpose okay
and you have a gift and that's your
purpose and I have an extreme view of
what a distraction is a distraction is
the devil that's dressed up as a
distraction and it's evil
because anything that takes you away
from your purpose in life is evil
anything that takes you away from your
purpose is evil because we were put here
to do something and and and God or the
universe wants you to fulfill that and
at first you have to know what that
purpose is you know those people are
very
far from understanding that thang I said
that's a deeper subject this this this
girl she knows that she has a talent of
music like she's she's very talented and
she just doesn't know how to go about it
but she's been distracted and she's been
distracted by herself she's been
distracted by the people she she allows
around her like there's so many things
taking her away and when I put it in the
perspective of oh that distraction is
evil I was like okay you got to make a
decision well which one are you gonna do
you're like you're a woman of God like
you're gonna you're gonna decide with
evil today is eat mystic distractions
yeah it's like it might be a it might
just be on Instagram like just like
scrolling through and now she's gonna be
able to have a conversation with herself
like is this taking me towards my
purpose it's like how I did the Dead or
Alive like she's gonna be like well is
this purpose or is this that evil thing
Charlie said oh this isn't oh yeah boom
I need to go that way yeah there's
something about the binary aspect of
that and the rule thing that we were
talking about earlier and and really
understanding that that this idea that
that our lives can be static or that
there is some form of stasis in our
lives which I think to some extent we
all we all kind of carry around and
believe on some level is a myth it's
it's an illusion because in every
thought that you entertain every
conversation that you have every
interaction every decision that you make
every behavior that you engage in is
either moving you in the direction of
fulfilling that purpose or helping you
to become healthier more self actualized
helping you to grow or it's moving you
away from that right it's moving you
into a regressive state and so scrolling
through Instagram is that really a
productive use of your time well it's
kind of benign but is it right if your
time crunch time is the ultimate
commodity this is what garyvee always
talks about it's about time right how
are you how are you exercising yourself
in the limited confines of time
hmm and when you know it your purposes
even if you don't I think that that that
having a level of mindfulness an extreme
level of mindfulness around that is the
differentiator between people who
actually achieve their goals and people
who end up sort of settling because
those are the people who will say they
don't have time and we do have time it's
a question of what is important to you
and how you're prioritizing that
allocation definitely and something just
popped up in my head about the purpose
thing and I think I know how to solve
that issue for everybody
uh-huh you know where charlie rocket cuz
you're wearing the Charlie Rocket
headband both so actually neither
neither of them is me um it's just my
marketing mind going to work so my
friend asked me yesterday we were
talking about he was like charlie like
you really got up my roommate actually
he's like Charlie you really got to help
people find their purpose and he's like
you should put together like a
step-by-step guide and I'm like a list
or God can't solve this problem and then
it hit me when I was explaining it to
him and it took me back to the example
of the four-minute mile example of like
oh is this impossible thing that nobody
could do everybody's tried and then once
one person did it everybody else just
broke that record and I was like oh okay
so if this purpose thing for a lot of
people seems impossible to find or do
people just have to see it done so I was
like how about we just tell a whole
bunch of stories find okay if there's
like 12 different personality types in
the world like me telling my story might
not like effect like a woman like who
has a different personality type so it's
like okay we need to take every
personality type in the world and then
we need to find stories of how those
certain people's success stories of how
those people found their purpose and if
somebody who's sitting behind the
computer
screen can see somebody like them who
they can truly relate to and just see
that that person found it and how they
did it through a story instead of a list
like we're reading like a nonfiction
book but just like a story then once
somebody sees it then people can do it
all the time just like the four-minute
model well it goes back to what we were
saying before the most powerful thing is
an incredible story well told right and
that's going to always trump some list
of things to do you know the quest
finding your purpose or unlocking what
is most important to you so that you can
live a meaningful purposeful life of
service is an incredibly personal thing
and you know there may be 12 personality
types but there's an infinite number of
specific unique life paths but you can't
tell something that is for yeah but the
story is like the permission this so I
look at like Google in data or books or
anything you search on Google as
information for the mind like it's a
search engine for your head right
gaining knowledge but when we hear an
amazing story it's like a search engine
to the heart and it's not verbatim what
that person is saying but it starts
conversations inside of yourself and
that's what we need more of we don't
need more information we need more
things that start inner conversations
and that's where the purpose comes from
the purpose doesn't come from oh this
person did this the purpose comes from
Wow I'm starting to have an inner
conversation and then I find the answer
within and I think that's what stories
do I agree with that purpose is entirely
a hard thing and it's about connection
with self and that that that the heart
is the conduit to that I think most
people are very disconnected from their
heart and disconnected from themselves
and when pressed to decide or articulate
what they're our purpose is or what
their mission is they're just grasping
at straws
and choosing something that is is very
likely not correct because of that
disconnection and in order to make that
connection that again is a very personal
thing there is no list like oh sit down
and connect with your heart like you
can't tell somebody to do that you have
to impact them in a in a fundamentally
emotional way and storytelling does that
you know what did it for me
and I realized it this morning what's up
Moana Moana Moana I realized that this
morning cuz that that movie I loved it
so much but I watched it this time last
year when I was really sick and Moana
kept it being called to the ocean and
then it was pulling her back but she
wanted to go but everybody kept pulling
her back and then she went into this
distant land away from home and she had
to essentially slay the dragon and
figure it out on her own away from
everybody that had been trying to help
her and she went and conquered that and
then she came back to save everybody
else that's my story
that's the hero's journey yeah you know
that's a very Joseph Campbell orchid you
know archetype of the hero's journey and
that is your story you know and and and
that's my story as well I mean I think
that's the story of everybody who's done
that internal search
mmm Anna had to wrestle with those
things you know themselves in solitary
um you know to to figure out who they
are so that they could come back to the
world and have something to give Yeah
right man thank you for being you thank
you for being you for this world
I appreciate that we really really
appreciate you like like me and my best
friend Scott like we idolize you and
we're like man where does which role run
we just need to run wherever you run so
like we Kaseem cuz we look at you as
like a superhero like yeah that's the
thing man like I'm just a dude to like
don't worry too much you know but we'll
go out and do some running man I've told
you like dirt maja knows just out there
this morning
can't wait
meet you up there we'll do a little
training how does that sound deal Yeah
right on my man cool dude
all right well that was great dude how
do you feel amazing you feel good some
rituals you know that's a big deal
no it's gonna be good dude thank you so
if people want to connect with you and
cheer you on
yes what's the best way for them to do
that Instagram Charlie jab Ally on
Instagram that CH AR li e j ay ba le Y
right and if if people want to learn
more about this like torch relay thing
and all of that is that just just
stating in your mind or is there
anything online where people can you
know tap into your solar scene dude and
and help help you to create this
community that you seek so I took a
one-year social media fast I got off I
got off all social media to reinvent in
2017 I did this post-it note and I put
it on my fridge rater and it was
contract to myself and I said I want to
do an Ironman and I'm gonna become top
1% of athletes in the world and I got
off social media and and I'll be back on
social media January 1st 2018 so yes if
you follow me everything will be posted
and you'll see a lot of you'll see a lot
of my missions that I'm on in life cool
and just to close it down maybe one last
thought to the person out there that
still struggles if if you're rock bottom
if you're if you're rock bottom and in a
really really really bad place please
email me I will help you
CEO charlie at gmail.com I will I really
want to only deal with people who are
severely rock bottom like I was and this
is this is this is my new life so I
would love to help anybody who is where
I was because I didn't have anybody who
was like me like I couldn't find
anything on the inner
of like people who exercised and gained
weight like I didn't have any answer so
if you really really are rock bottom
please email me and I'll be there for
you you might be getting quite a few
emails that's perfectly fine I got
plenty of time
awesome dude you're an inspiration I
can't wait to see where you take this
and I'm excited for you Charlie thank
you rich thanks for joining the podcast
especially are you talking to you yeah
man
peace my main players